françaises français
merci de m'accueillir chez vous ce soir
et de m'accorder ces quelques minutes
d'attention
en quelques jours nous allons ensemble
élire un président pour la république et
choisir une politique pour la france
c'est pour nous tous un grand honneur et
une grande responsabilité
nous avons la chance en effet d'être des
français c'est à dire que par le seul
fait de notre naissance les enfants
d'une nation très ancienne et très
illustre très belle aussi
c'est elle qui assure la sécurité de
notre peuple
sa liberté son espoir en retour de lui
devant le respect l'amour est aussi nous
devons s'il le faut mourir pour elle au
moment donc de nous déterminer
nous aurons à nous élever le coeur et
l'esprit
au delà même de nos légitimes
aspirations personnelles et à penser que
nos actes que nos décisions vont peser
sur le destin de la france
j'essaierai de vous aider à voir clair
je vous dirais qu'elles sont mais
critique mes propositions avec droiture
et franchise
tout au long de cette campagne
électorale je vous exposerai les
propositions concrètes de mon programme
de salut public
je sais que vous êtes inquiet troublé
que vous percevez les menaces qui pèsent
sur l'indépendance de notre pays sur
notre avenir est aussi sur votre
situation personnelle et familiale vous
sentez bien que la décadence chi minh
qui mine nos institutions nos lois nos
moeurs que le désordre dans la rue à
l'école ou au travail nous affaiblisse
au moment même où une crise mondiale de
l'énergie nous impose une révision
déchirante de nos objectifs économiques
et je le sens comme vous je suis inquiet
comme vous
parce que je suis un professionnel parce
que je suis un salarié comme vous parce
que je suis un père de famille et aussi
parce que je suis un citoyen les
responsabilités de la situation actuelle
de la france
1 comme il est vrai pour une part aux
événements et à la marche du monde mais
elles tiennent surtout aux hommes qui
ont gouverné notre pays depuis 15 ans
aux dirigeants de l'ex majorité qui
viennent aujourd'hui nous proposer tel
les pompiers incendiaires d'éteindre le
feu qu'ils ont eux même allumé malgré
les atouts considérables qu'ils ont eus
entre les mains majorité stable durée
stabilité ces hommes politiques ont été
incapables ou impuissants à enrayer le
désordre dans nos cités dans nos écoles
dans nos moeurs incapables aussi de
réformer les structures d'un état et
d'une administration pléthorique et
impuissants les chances de la france ont
été par eux à l'instar de celle du
sahara français dilapidé au fil des
années en faisant avec les voix de la
droite la politique de la gauche
ils ont même réussi à amener les
communistes au bord du pouvoir et ce ne
sont pas des mots qui assureront la
nécessaire reconnaissance de la france
il suffit pas de vouloir continuer dans
le changement ou changer dans la
continuité
il faut immédiatement changé et d'abord
changer l'état il n'y a pas de nation
libre 100 et apports et il n'y a pas de
citoyen libre 100 et ajuste c'est
pourquoi nous devons construire un état
juste et fort il faut aussi changer
l'esprit civique en restaurant
l'autorité de la loi car il n'y a pas de
société sans loi et il n'y a pas de loi
sans sanction comme il n'y a pas de
liberté sans ordre il faut aussi que
l'état et les hommes publics donnent
l'exemple en respectant le eux-mêmes
l'autorité de l'état et de la loi
il faut aussi changer de politique celle
pratiquée
jusqu'ici a échoué et la grande
espérance de grandeur et de renouveau né
en 1958 a été cruellement déçus elle
s'est dissoute dans les scandales
l'inflation et la chienlit
alors il faut changer les hommes puisque
ceux ci ont été impuissants et
incapables de prévoir et de maîtriser
les forces de décomposition et de
désintégration qui menacent l'état et la
nation votre choix vous allez le faire
en deux temps dans quinze jours vous
allez voter pour celui des candidats
dont la personnalité et le programme
vous plaît le plus faites le sans vous
inquiéter des sondages des pronostics
des prévisions ou des calculs tactiques
au premier tour il faut voter pour ses
idées second tour vous choisirez parmi
ceux que le suffrage universel les deux
personnalités que je croise universelle
aura désigné celle de votre choix
vous avez donc à choisir en même temps
un homme et une politique en ce qui
concerne l'homme je me permets de vous
conseiller de vous poser trois questions
est ce un homme libre est ce un homme de
caractère
est ce un homme de bon sens je vous
conseille aussi de le choisir plus en
fonction de ses actions passées qu'en
fonction de ses actuels promesses
électorales car vous savez comme moi
créé les promesses électorales dur comme
les roses l'espace d'un matin la
politique que vous choisirez doit être
claire et courageuse défier vous de ce
qui vous propose et vous promettre des
lendemains qui chantent
votre choix est somme toute assez simple
si vous êtes satisfaits heureux
prosper rassurer et bien vous pouvez
faire confiance à ceux qui ont dirigé le
pays depuis 15 ans aux trois candidats
de la majorité
chaban hoyé giscard tous ministres ou
anciens ministres de la vème république
sont des hommes en qui vous serez avec
lesquels vous serez satisfaits de
continuer sur le chemin qui a été choisi
si vous pensez au contraire qu'il faut
tout bouleverser tentez l'expérience
marxiste installer les communistes au
pouvoir alors n'hésitez pas voter pour
monsieur mitterrand mais si vous pensez
qu'il faut changer politique
si vous souhaitez l'ordre dans la
liberté la paix sociale la justice
si vous voulez un état fort et juste
dans une france libre et fraternelle
alors votez jean marie le pen route et
ça libe
[Musique]